the Joe Rogan experience do wonders when
I see a crowd of Mexican conspiracy
theorists oh you try to breach those
subjects go hey stop stop stop stop I
can't I can't do that he's crazy then
what you should really lose the Eddy
about all the people that make tunnels
under the earth hey hey hey hey hey I
like when people come out to me I got
people coming up to me and they're like
all alien that they still think I'm the
2005 dude where you've evolved aliens
been we were we've evolved from aliens
and the split the whole Anunnaki story
man it's hard for they're so into it and
it's like wonder how do I tell this guy
that I don't believe sometimes you know
what I had a guy the other night I was
just like I'm not even gonna say nothing
no more yes [ __ ] ills we wish our
dear neighbor split do you ever could
not not miss a leg bro what happened Oh
like mm hanging out doing bong head
someone documentaries yeah all that [ __ ]
nobody nobody watch maybe there's a lot
of ties maybe there's that [ __ ] a
hundred wait I thousand wait but it's
very hard to watch more space
documentaries than me and you dude come
on documentary 2 notches alien we would
just sit there and there's like 12 parts
to like this BBC universe remember that
giant alien bong that I had yeah yellow
fish bong red band has that thing nobody
was into space and aliens more than us
no you had that [ __ ] Roswell poster
on dude we were balls deep in that [ __ ]
let me tell you something man it got
fired up and again when I watched that
Bob Lazar documentary when Bob Lazar was
saying things in the 1990s that became
true in the late - in the 2000 teens -
in terms of like element 115
that they had this thing that they could
propel these spaceships with and they
were saying there's no such thing it was
like there's a thing they have it it's
from another planet he explained the
propulsion system he explained all this
stuff it sounds like such nonsense but I
believe Bob Lazar believes all that [ __ ]
I believe we don't believe it's true I
believe you set up they let him talk to
her like how they're gonna let him do
Netflix and they're gonna come on JRE
they're gonna let him do go on Larry
King
Eddie Bravo with the 3d chest they want
him to do that it's up if you're on
Netflix they want the deep state wants
you on Netflix so it's a good thing it's
a good thing too I think he believes it
you know just like William Cooper I
think he he figured out he got set up
they were trying to get him to believe
that alien spacecraft coming and all
that because he would his job at the
Office of Naval Intelligence William
Cooper he wrote behold a pale horse he
wrote that book he's like probably
considered the Helio Gracie of
conspiracy theories William Cooper he
was in charge of putting together the
documents for these top-secret naval
Office of Naval Intelligence meetings
and he was reading him and going well is
he killed in a shootout they shot his
ass dude but he was killing a shootout
like in the front of this house there he
was talking too much he predicted Osama
bin Laden before 9/11 I don't know if
you know this there's video on YouTube
you can watch is William Cooper you know
he goes out space about like bases on
the moon where aliens had babies he
evolved he you got to do that all the
time sort of like you're not aliens
anymore and now he really don't know
because he's a big part of it he's a big
part of it of what he's a big part of me
going oh because he he is the one who
opened my eyes to the fact that he
thought he was being set up into a
thought they're trying to get us to
believe in aliens so they could fake an
alien attack so that'll sure in the New
World Order cuz what happens if the
aliens attack we all unite and all the
movies you see them in the movies like
oh they're attacking let's call China
China's got this new thing and the
Russia then we're all together we all
unite
that's the whole purpose of everything
it's always been about everything
there's some
pieces how do we do this but wait a
minute who's the master [ __ ]
puppeteer this along now I need an hour
to explain all that that's too long
that's too much that's too long I still
on but William Cooper he was the guy who
he was like aliens exist I'm looking at
these documents they're having these
meetings about this crashed alien
aircraft so he's out at he's got his own
little private radio and like or not
private radio but I don't like in the
late 80s early 90s on radio whatever
that before the way before that some
sort of show and then he's like oh these
[ __ ] are setting me up there's
this is all [ __ ] he goes they
they're setting up a fake alien invasion
that's what they're doing
[Applause]